six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's try our caller from the six-30
area code six three zero you are on the
air hi my name is Gerardo lone from
Chicago quick question there was a monk
debate on Friday between Michael Eric
Dyson I forgot the woman's name on the
panel and Jordan Peterson
those carriers just felt like there was
a certain part where Michael Eric Dyson
called Jordan Peterson angry white man I
was curious what you thought about that
specifically the fact that Michael Eric
Dyson was defending political
correctness right and use sort of like
what some consider a politically
incorrect insult towards Jordan and
Jordan ended up being insulted by it
funny enough he's defending political
correctness seem like Ted of ironic just
just her thoughts sometimes yeah I mean
it the entire thing was a mess right so
so like Michael Eric Michael Eric Dyson
says that Jordan Peterson is an angry
white guy and then so he Michael Eric
Dyson is arguing that political
correctness is good because it prevents
I guess offensive things from being said
or people are shamed effaces they said
offensive things or I don't want to
mischaracterize his argument but he said
something which falls out outside of
what he's sort of saying should be the
policy or the the norm
Jordan Peterson who says being offended
isn't an argument and part of existing
in the world is that you need to be open
to being offended because sometimes good
conversations take place when that
happens he seemed to be offended by
being called an angry white guy I mean I
just I watch the pieces of the entire
thing I didn't I didn't watch the whole
thing I thought that it was a lot of
people who like to hear themselves talk
and I'm not doing the false equivalency
thing where I say both know Anthony both
sides went off the rails I you know it
was it held my attention and I was sort
of curious about the feel of the thing I
didn't so much care about every argument
made during the hour and a half or two
hours or whatever but quite frankly I
found that that exchange was so silly
because they both all of a sudden seemed
to be doing what it was that they were
arguing against right Michael Eric Dyson
being I guess you
say politically incorrect and then
Jordan Pederson Peterson being insulted
and offended by something even though he
says we shouldn't worry about political
correctness is to talk it's a toxic
movement so I didn't know what to make
of it yeah right on yeah I'm not
offended either those two guys I just
thought it was kind of hilarious that it
was therefore they did thank you for the
call I appreciate it yeah people haven't
seen that and if it's your thing I mean
you know check it out I know that
there's many people who enjoyed it
greatly